Thomas Thomas is producing another epic
that is reimagining maybe the most
iconic monster of them all Kong Skull
Island please welcome skull Islands
director Jordan best Roberts
that's the greatest beard I've seen in
my life uh make sure I said that
cribbage it's a morning pop Robert so
yes
[ __ ] you shaved this morning you have
more testosterone than any man I've ever
met
I tried save myself uh okay should we
get the talent out here I think we
should I'm super excited to be here to
show you guys what we brought and to
bring our cast out Kong is film history
it's what made me as a child love genre
storytelling in special effects and so
I'm so excited to show you some stuff
and to bring your cast including John
Goodman
you
Corey Hawkins yeah
Jason [ __ ] Mitchell
brie Larson
and this next person you need to know
something about me I like dad jokes and
I'm like bad puns
this guy likes to keep it pretty low-key
Tom Hiddleston
yeah alright let's talk about this
Jordan Kong has been an iconic part of
the culture since the 1930s I mean many
people consider this to be the original
monster the original I mean it's got a
tall you feel a sense of responsibility
taking this on did it feel like a heavy
thing to take on you just you had fun
with it right away
of course it's a huge responsibility
Kong is film history Kong is where our
special effects come from Kong is where
Jean rub mainstream and it's a enormous
responsibility but it's an enormous
honor and that's why we tried to an
assemble and cast like this and and it
just an incredible team to sort of tell
people a new story within that mythology
because we've seen the old story over
and over again we've seen the beauty in
the beasts tail so it's a huge
responsibility and that's why part of
our responsibility is to show them in
new story within that mythology now it
takes place in the 1970s was that
important to you is there anything that
you you got from having it be in the
1970s that gives it an extra oomph for
you I mean what's not cool about
choppers and napalm and King Kong
no but seriously the 70s is such an
interesting time and it's a blast time
in the world where sort of myth could
still exist in what you could have these
unknown things and we love to take in
sort of characters from that era in
which the world much like now is in
chaos and thrusting them into the
unknown and having them look at
something look at Kong and stare up at
it and if we say that's a god how else
do you reason this thing towering over
you it's from it's from a different time
and what does that do to the people so
the 70s yeah it's cool it's
aesthetically amazing there's so much
fun things to do with it
but it really stems from our access
point with the characters okay I have a
question for Bri which is your last film
famously you're in a very small room and
now you are everywhere you're shooting
in these incredible locations what was
that transition like for you it was more
comfortable yeah to be outside yeah yeah
I would think so yeah I had better
insoles in my shoes
I had sunscreen uh it was just I just
found a better Airbnb it was really very
nice handle that well Tom your group
your character is leading a group of
humans into this island giant weird
territory terrifying creatures is this
year like your first time playing an
action hero first of all very nice to
see you all thank you for the warm
welcome and thank you for calling me an
action hero Conan appreciate that um
thank you ma'am on the left yes I love
you too so yeah I play a character
called Captain James Conrad and he is a
British SAS formerly British SAS officer
with a specialist skill in in tracking
and jungle survival very unique set of
skills very unique set of skills and
it's interesting is the the expedition
that all the characters go on is that
we're all given a pitch that the
technology that we now use in apps like
Google Earth was in its infancy in the
early 70s and NASA had a wing called
Landsat and they were taking pictures of
the Earth from space and they can see an
island in the South Pacific and they
don't on it's protected by a storm
system and they can't get into that
storm system so they send a group of
soldiers and explorers and a war
photographer played by Bree and and we
all feel overqualified for this mission
I'm an anti-war photographer though yeah
of course yeah to be clear about that
not for work yeah but so so
samuel l.jackson plays left-handed
colonel of an air cab brigade who has
many men under his wing so he's
commander in the sky and captain Conrad
is the commander on the ground and as
for the rest you'll just have to wait
and see all right now this is a question
for the whole cast what was this you're
taking on an adventure when you sign on
for a role like this you're signing on
for an adventure you're working together
you're your characters all have to blend
what was this talk about that a little
bit what was it like for you as a group
working on this film did you enjoy the
process was it hard work it looks a
little arduous absolutely I mean like
going all over the world and doing all
these different things is already a has
its greatness within itself but as an
actor when you're actually in the
elements when you're actually in a
bamboo forest when you're actually in
water in Vietnam up to your chest it
adds a whole different element you know
and all these different personalities
and all these different people come
together to make a really really really
boss squad you know we all have
different ways of approaching things and
I think we did a really really really
good job I think like to be honest like
I feel like and I say this but it really
did feel like guerilla filmmaking like
like we'd all right I know all pun
intended you'll be penalized for that
later but it was cool because like like
literally we're making this huge
big-budget film with these great actors
right and and Jordan at one moment would
be like okay no no no you know the
lights going down over here let's just
and he was strapped on a camera and just
and we would go shoot it you know to me
whether we were up to here in water and
Vietnam or like you know in in the
valleys in Hawaii or you know it was
just it was it was just fun to be able
to do that
and it gives Skull Island kind of a
character of itself like Scarlett takes
on you know its own its own character
you know what I mean yeah so it's yeah
this is a lot about you know humans
battling
elements and our inability to coexist
with them right and I think we all had
to come to terms with the fact that we
have a hard time coexisting with them in
actuality there were moments when and
because we shot for so long and in three
different countries we were dealing with
extreme like we are I'm wearing pretty
much the same costume through this whole
movie and you're going through rain we
got rained out of our locations flooded
out of our location some day and we
never changed attacked by bugs
extreme heat yeah they were going
through water I mean there was just so
many things that went through this but
it's also just important you know
because they are dealing with all these
CG creatures in Kong to put them in a
place there's so much CG in these movies
these days I think you guys in audiences
know one stuff feels fake you know we
all grew up and fell in love with movies
that were tactile and real and so we
wanted to take this cast this amazing
cast and put them in real places so the
majority of what you're looking at is
real so really the main buy is Kong they
they were that those places were
beautiful and terrifying and in
Australia I remember one night we were
filming and it was a silly person
filming into the about 2:00 in the
morning in in a rainforest in Australia
and with him standing at the end of the
night we realized there was a snake in
the monitor tent and they have some
dangerous snakes in Australia yeah and
in the swamps in in in in been in
Vietnam we you know we would we as jason
says we're up to our waist in swamp
water and getting to know each other
very well
and we've all got wet suits on
underneath our costumes and I remember
that there are things that can crawl
into the warm spaces in oh oh yeah these
are cleansing experiences but also the
amazing thing about that is normally
when you take a film can you take a cast
and you put them in these like really
harsh conditions people get angry real
quick when you're up to literally up
into muck to hear people get cold they
get tired whatever and then you're in
the middle of Vietnam where the first
movie to ever shoot there like this and
you're literally these guys days at a
time literally up to here in water and
no one would complain these guys would
never complain the crew
never complained because you would look
around and you're like oh my God look at
where we are right now look at how about
beautiful yeah it's like what a blessing
this is to be able to be here and to do
this and so it really was this kind of
surreal thing where like no one really
sort of complained about what was going
on because we all knew it was such a
magical thing to be able to be me you
played a little bit yeah and after we
wrap you know we just go and sing
karaoke guy right here is like you know
the reason they went some karaoke I
didn't have enough ass it's me versus
karaoke this world here we go oh we
almost got it we almost got it we almost
chopped it and then we didn't get it we
just give it up for one of my favorite
people of all time mr. John Goodman I'm
just gonna that's why I got into this
because I'd heard a lot about Kong over
the years ah you never knew what Kong
was gonna show up some days sometimes he
had a rough night
Eddie's always one of these guys stayed
in this trailer and I had to call him
Kong or mr. Kong you couldn't address
him with his real name leo
Oh mr. Kong through the whole thing and
that's way he wanted to keep it ah
when the chips are down he's hell of a
performer he's got the goods and I think
over the years he's earned the right to
be a little cranky
yeah in the morning he was you know like
20 minutes late all the Tempur makeup um
but he was never drunk on sad I guess a
lot of the reputation I've heard about
him over the years is riding on top of
taxicabs to get there and chartering
boats and putting in on company money it
turned out to be a good guy he won't do
Pross though he just won't do press now
now he's earned that right yeah
real shame II couldn't be here today
real shame real prima donna we have time
for one question from the audience
that's just the way it's going today oh
not everybody all at once
hello guys how's it going
my question and I have a question what
did you have for breakfast
oh um wish I had a Luna Bar oh good what
flavor
I was coconut chocolate dope hey shut up
to Luna bars everybody okay sorry love
you love you wanted by the way a little
bit more about you um my name is
Dominique I'm from Colorado
Oh Dominica nikken great hey Dominique
my one question is what is your guys's
favorite thing to get out - what is your
go-to neck Netflix and chill oh I don't
know if it gets geeky when I never
listen chill but hey wait do you mean
like what we watch or what we play what
we watch oh okay okay mr. ed movie
whatever you got mr. mister robot mr.
robot on my ears mr. robot play my geek
oh I'm just a big gamer I grew up on
video games I don't have time to play
games anymore which is a real bummer but
every time you can go and lose yourself
I'm just fascinated in like new forms of
storytelling you play gimmick journey
and you're like oh my god Holly journey
web never experienced this before or you
know everything happened with VR it's
incredible but I don't know I'm a dork I
like to watch Rosanna and say the lines
before I actually
and sometimes I come up with better
lines it's fun it keeps me in the house
the wife you can watch Tommy everything
you want to throw in there anything
you're liking to watch these days which
favorite movies favorite TV show I was
just gonna leave it with John Goodman
and Rosanna
I know I just wanted to do that to you
are you Pokemon going I'm no sir have
you guys watched stranger things yet
I love stranger playing aah oh we
haven't talked we got to talk about we
got its orbit we got to talk about a sir
Game of Thrones um whoo that went over
well how about this one
Mario Kart yeah sometimes when I
sometimes when I'm sick I go watch
rewatch all the Fawlty Towers from a
long time yes Tom Manley reads poetry
though like he's a pretty studious guy
he look reads very like dense novels all
right I'm getting these serious wrap it
up a sign and electric defrauding in
various places so let us have a huge
round of applause
Hong Skull Island opens March 10th 2017
thank you very much
what
you